[Música]
de manuel macrón se impuso a marín lepén
en la segunda vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales en francia akrón será el
primer mandatario reelecto en dos
décadas pero esta vez con un margen de
votos mucho menor que en los comicios de
2017 lepén aceptó la derrota y celebró
el mejor resultado electoral en la
historia de la extrema derecha tenemos
reporte de cada campaña
uno de cada cuatro electores no acudió a
las urnas este domingo en las
presidenciales francesas se trata de una
tasa del 28 2% aproximadamente la tasa
más alta en una segunda vuelta desde
el presidente ucraniano volodymyr
selenski y los secretarios de estado y
defensa de eeuu se reunieron este
domingo inquieto es la visita de más
alto rango por parte de washington desde
el comienzo de la invasión rusa que este
domingo cumple dos meses
a las 24
jeffrey en colaboración con france 2 y
france inter con información de ipsos y
sobras teorías
bienvenidos a una nueva emisión
informativa en la pantalla de france 24
gracias por permanecer con nosotros yo
soy juan pupiales el presidente de
manuel macro es el ganador de la segunda
vuelta de las elecciones francesas el
jefe de estado venció a la
ultraderechista marine lepén y
permanecerá otros cinco años más en el
palacio del elíseo según la más reciente
estimación de ipsos sorpresa seria para
france24 macro no obtuvo el 58,8 por
ciento de los votos frente al 41 2% del
epen en un cara a cara que reeditó la
segunda vuelta de
desde los campos de marte el presidente
de macrón ofreció su discurso triunfal
el mandatario reconoció que obtuvo votos
no por parte de electores que
simpatizaron con él sino de personas que
querían frenar a la extrema derecha por
su parte el epen aplaudió el apoyo y
recibió en esta jornada habló del apoyo
que recibe en esta jornada y celebro el
mejor resultado en la historia de la
extrema derecha en francia
nuestro compañero andrés granadillo
tiene el recuento del día emanuel macrón
se queda en el elíseo el escrutinio da
como ganador al actual presidente sobre
su rival la ultraderechista marine lepén
con 50 de 88 % se impuso en las
presidenciales aunque ganó el resultado
fue menor al de la contienda de 2017
cuando también se enfrentó al epen en su
discurso de victoria en el campo de
marte anunció que buscará la unión de la
francia polarizada además reconoció que
no todos sus votos fueron de adhesión a
sus políticas sino de oposición al ep de
que todos juntos tendremos que trabajar
por esa unidad que será la única que nos
permitirá vivir más felices y enfrentar
los retos que nos esperan
y
los años que vienen no serán tranquilos
con toda seguridad pero sí serán años
históricos y todos juntos sabremos
escribirlos para nuestras generaciones
pese a su holgada victoria es consciente
de las críticas a su gobierno crisis
como las manifestaciones de los chalecos
amarillos el manejo de la pandemia y la
guerra en ucrania por eso anunció un
cambio de este próximo quinquenio
por todo esto quiero junto a todos
ustedes afrontar los próximos cinco años
esta nueva era no será la continuidad
del mandato que acaba de terminar
[Música]
sino la invención colectiva de un nuevo
método para cinco años que serán mejores
al servicio de nuestro país y de nuestra
juventud donde las funciones
[Aplausos]
marine lepén recibió el 41 2 %
interpretó a los resultados como una
victoria el resultado de esta noche
representa en sí mismo de todas maneras
una victoria sorprendente esta francia
tan olvidada nosotros no la olvidaremos
estamos más determinados que nunca y
nuestra voluntad de ayudar a los
franceses es aún mayor además de
anunciar que sería oposición de macrón
llamó a votar masivamente las
legislativas para hacerse con el
parlamento esta noche lanzamos la gran
batalla electoral de las legislativas
[Aplausos]
librar esta batalla al lado del señor
con todos los que tuvieron la valentía
de oponerse al señor marco en la segunda
vuelta la extrema derecha tuvo una
votación sin precedentes en estas
elecciones aunque la abstención fue la
más alta desde los años 60
efectivamente tal y como se esperaba la
ascensión fue una de las protagonistas
de la jornada según las cifras de ipsos
sobre este área para france24 el 28,2
por ciento de los electores se
abstuvieron de acudir a las urnas la
cifra más alta en una segunda vuelta
desde 1969 hace cinco años en 2017 la
abstención fue de 25 a 44 por ciento de
acuerdo con datos del ministerio del
interior a su vez fue 6 puntos
porcentuales más alta que la de 2012 y
casi 10 por ciento más que la abstención
de 2007 mientras que en 2002 un 20 como
29 por ciento de los electores
decidieron no participar en los comicios
hablemos ahora de la evolución de la
votación entre emmanuel macrón y marine
lepén respecto a la segunda vuelta de
las elecciones francesas en 2017 de
macrón ganó estos comicios con el 66,1
por ciento de las papeletas frente al
33,9 por ciento del epen fue un margen
de más de 30 puntos porcentuales
respecto a los 17 puntos que se
registraron en los comicios de este
domingo de acuerdo con la más reciente
estimación esta fue en 2017 la primera
vez en la historia de que en una segunda
vuelta nuevos partidos ni de la derecha
ni de la izquierda tradicional de
francia
y para los detalles de cómo se vivió
esta jornada crucial en las campañas de
macrón y del epen tenemos el reporte de
nuestras periodistas de natalia ruiz
giraldo y erika olavarría empezamos con
natalia ruiz ella siguió el evento de
manuel ma chrome quien se hizo esperar
antes de ofrecer su discurso triunfal
reinvención y unidad s bien puede ser el
lema de emanuel a marco para los
próximos cinco años aquí en el campo de
marte con a la torre eiffel
como fondo pues emanuel ama con celebró
su victoria y su reelección a la
presidencia de francia agradeció por
supuesto a aquellas personas que votaron
por él pero también en especial a
aquellas personas que votaron por él no
por adhesión sino para hacer frente y
frenar la llegada de la extrema derecha
al elíseo él hablaba de reinvención de
cinco años en los que la pueda hacer
tener un nuevo método para construir
algo mejor una sociedad más justa una
sociedad
en la que los hombres y las mujeres sean
más más iguales pero también hablaba de
una sociedad en la que hay que trabajar
en la unidad del sabe que hay mucha
rabia que hay mucho desacuerdo y que
estas personas deben ser escuchadas y es
él quien debe darles respuesta esta no
fue una celebración llena de júbilo de
ese jolgorio que se vivió hace cinco
años sino en realidad
fue una celebración un poco parca de
casi de alivio para las personas que
estaban aquí presentes quienes hasta el
último momento sintieron incertidumbre
de lo que podía terminar esta segunda
vuelta por ahora queda saber cuál será
la estrategia de manuel mccone para las
elecciones legislativas del mes de junio
porque de esa elección él no habló en su
discurso
y pocos minutos después del cierre de
las urnas marine lepén entregó un
discurso en el que habló de la derrota
lo que no le impidió celebrar el avance
histórico de la ultraderecha además
empezó a centrarse en las elecciones
legislativas de junio nuestra periodista
erika olavarría estuvo presente en la
campaña del epen y nos envió el
siguiente reporte
una derrota con gusto a victoria siempre
he querido interpretar la jornada
electoral de esta noche aquí en el
comando de mavi nos ven empezando por la
propia candidata que cuando salió a
analizar los resultados y agradecer a
sus seguidores se sintió profundamente
tocada por la votación obtenida en
ultramar en el campo y en la provincia
ya dijo he sido la voz de los
silenciados agradeció sobre todo esos
votos que consiguió entre la primera y
segunda vuelta e impulsada por esta
votación histórica de la extrema derecha
propuso su nueva batalla que será las
elecciones legislativas de junio de este
año entre los votantes de marín le pen
que se encontraban esta noche aquí en el
bosque de bolonia había justamente eso
una sensación de decepción por la
derrota pero también una felicidad por
un resultado histórico para una
candidata salida de la extrema derecha
además
un contexto de alta abstención política
así que la batalla no ha hecho sino
comenzar para gabino el joven que ahora
tiene sus ojos puestos en julio
tenemos que hablar ahora del avance de
la izquierda en francia algo que quedó
reflejado en esta primera algo que no ha
desaparecido del todo de hecho en la
primera vuelta del escrutinio un tercio
de los votantes franceses eligió a uno
de los seis candidatos de izquierda
especialmente a jean-luc mélenchon
candidato de la francia insumisa que se
quedó a sólo unos 400.000 votos para
pasar a la segunda vuelta entonces que
le espera a los partidos de izquierda y
al electorado
el veterano izquierdista de jean luc
mélenchon se ha convertido en el rostro
de la política progresista francesa el
político de la izquierda se quedó por
muy poco por fuera de la ronda final de
las elecciones presidenciales del 2022
era uno de los seis candidatos de
izquierdas incluidos los verdes los
comunistas y los una vez poderosos
socialistas en total menos de un tercio
de los franceses votaron por un
progresista después de los resultados
los seguidores de mel en son culparon a
los otros partidos de quitarles valiosos
votos a su candidato a pesar de ello
insisten en que la lucha está lejos de
terminar
y
yo he vivido a los franceses que me
elijan como su primer ministro votando
una mayoría de diputados del partido de
francia insumisa y de nuestro grupo
unión popular hay una tercera vuelta por
venir en una segunda vuelta sino también
una tercera
la tercera ronda a la que se refiere m
link son son las elecciones
parlamentarias de junio su partido franz
insumisa ha llamado a los políticos a
unirse a una coalición de izquierdas de
este modo espera ganar suficientes
escaños en la asamblea nacional para
reforzar un gobierno de cohabitación con
el poder el último gobierno de
cohabitación en francia se remonta a
1997 jacques chirac tuvo que trabajar
por el primer ministro socialista lionel
jospin el propio mel en jong fue
ministro subalterno en ese gobierno en
representación del ala de la izquierda
del partido socialista pero en el 2008
renunció a su familia política para
crear un movimiento más radical que ha
ido creciendo desde entonces a pesar de
la elección del socialista françois
hollande en 2012 el partido seguía
dividido entre los defensores de un
programa de izquierdas partidarios de
reformas laborales favorables para las
empresas
la marca ha sido dañada no son sólo los
votantes de la clase trabajadora
el hombre que veo land se eligió para
ayudarle con algunas de las reformas más
controvertidas fue manuel macro el joven
ministro crearía más tarde su propio
partido centrista en el 2017 se presentó
con éxito a las elecciones arrasando con
gran parte del voto socialdemócrata
desde entonces los socialistas han sido
superados por macrón en la derecha y mel
en sión en la izquierda llegando a un
mínimo histórico de menos del 2% el 10
de abril en las próximas semanas se verá
si los partidos de la izquierda
fracturados pueden dejar de lado sus
diferencias y unirse
[Música]
francia es una república
presidencialista y algunos critican que
el jefe de estado tiene demasiado poder
tras esta jornada de fiesta electoral
revisemos los poderes del mandatario en
el siguiente informe cuando yo como
presidente de la república no seré
presidente de todo jefe de todo y
finalmente responsable de narón
sampdoria cuando se presentó a las
elecciones presidenciales francesas de
joshua holón señaló una crítica ya
conocida el alcance de un presidente
francés es muy amplio quizás demasiado
amplio en francia el jefe de estado es
un líder versátil con varios sombreros y
algunos privilegios controvertidos como
comandante del poder ejecutivo nombra al
primer ministro y preside el gabinete
establece la agenda política de la
nación proponiendo leyes y si los
legisladores se interponen puede
disolver el parlamento u organizar un
referendo popular
el presidente francés es también el jefe
de las fuerzas armadas y por tanto tiene
el poder de desplegar tropas en el
extranjero y ordenar el uso de la fuerza
nuclear
el mandatario representa a francia en la
escena internacional negociando y
ratificando tratados y supervisando el
cierre de acuerdos comerciales
estratégicos en ocasiones el presidente
puede ser la encarnación física de la
política exterior francesa cuando
jacques chirac visitó jerusalén en
1996 su exasperación ante el fuerte
dispositivo de seguridad israelí se
consideró una señal de la postura más
pro palestina de francia que quieren que
vuelva a mi avión y regrese a francia
eso es lo que quieren por encima de todo
el presidente tiene una última carta el
artículo 16 de la constitución le
permite asumir el control ejecutivo
total si la nación se encuentra bajo una
grave amenaza saldo gol quien elaboró
las prerrogativas del alto cargo restó
importancia a cualquier amenaza
porque quieren que empiece una carrera
como dictador a los 67 años
los presidentes franceses están en el
centro del poder pero tienen sus velas
en cada encierro de la política nacional
dejamos a un lado a las elecciones
francesas y hablamos de la invasión rusa
a ucrania que este domingo cumple dos
meses el presidente ucraniano volodymyr
selenski se reunió este domingo con los
secretarios de estado y defensa de eeuu
anthony blinken y lloyd austin se trata
de un encuentro celebrado en kiev según
un asesor del presidente excelentes que
sería la visita de más alto rango por
parte de la casa blanca a este país el
del comienzo de la guerra es un
encuentro que habría llegado en medio de
continuos llamados por parte de
excelencia y para que washington los
apoyen con un armamento de mayor
capacidad para hacer frente a las tropas
rusas y se tratara
y este domingo precisamente las tropas
de rusia continuaron con su asedio sobre
la ciudad de mariupol esto denunciaron
las autoridades de ucrania tras asegurar
que unos 20.000 ciudadanos han fallecido
desde el inicio de la ofensiva moscú
continúa atacando la metalúrgica de asof
tal el último punto de la resistencia
aquí permanecen unos 2.000 combatientes
ucranianos junto con 1000 civiles en
total unas 100.000 personas permanecen
permanecen en toda esta urbe en medio de
fallidos intentos de evacuación un
consejero de presidente se les quiere
reconoció este domingo que hicieron una
propuesta de negociaciones al kremlin
el invitamos a los rusos a celebrar una
ronda especial de conversaciones en el
lugar justo al lado de los muros de asof
tal pedimos a nuestros homólogos rusos
que negocien un alto el fuego inmediato
en semana santa la provisión de
corredores humanitarios y la liberación
e intercambio de nuestras tropas para
todos los prisioneros de guerra de la
federación rusa estamos esperando la
respuesta de la federación rusa y les
recordamos que no les gustarán las
consecuencias allí en el kremlin si no
lo hacen
tú respondes previamente desde nuestra
enviada especial a ucrania eren sabio
nos actualizó sobre la situación en
territorio ucraniano en esta jornada que
justamente coincidió además con la
celebración de la pascua ortodoxa
religión predominante en rusia y ucrania
y que este año llegó con catedrales en
ruinas las sirenas se han vuelto a
disparar en el este de ucrania también
las hemos oído nosotras aquí en mi pro
donde nos encontramos la localidad de
poltava a poca distancia de aquí ha sido
alcanzada por nuevo ataque según
informaciones del gobierno ucraniano se
trataría de al menos cinco misiles que
habrían impactado contra infraestructura
de esta ciudad que además también está
ubicada a poca distancia de jarc y otra
ciudad martirizada por los
enfrentamientos que han continuado a
producirse durante el día de hoy y
también ha habido ataques en nikoláyev y
en la ciudad de gerson ocupada por las
fuerzas rusas hace varias semanas de
esta forma este país ha vivido la pascua
ortodoxa una fiesta religiosa muy
importante tanto para los ucranianos
como para los rusos que sin embargo la
población de este país ha vivido con
inquietud y desazón pero la fiesta fue
especialmente solemne para ucrania cuyos
ciudadanos salieron a recibir la
bendición pese a los peligros y
angustias de la guerra a pesar de los
llamamientos de personajes como el
secretario general de la onu y del
propio papá francisco no hubo otro agua
durante el fin de semana festivo veamos
el reporte
[Música]
en la majestuosa catedral de cristo
salvador los residentes de moscú
celebran la pascua con gran alegría y en
presencia de vladimir putin patria creel
es un aliado del presidente ruso durante
el fin de semana festivo pidió el fin de
la guerra en ucrania pero no la condenó
mientras que jeff de pie dentro de la
iglesia de santa sofía el presidente
ucraniano entregó su mensaje de pascua a
la gente puede que sea dueño de la gran
festividad de hoy nos da la gran
esperanza y la creencia de que la luz
vencerá a la oscuridad el bien vencer al
mal no paramos solo la vida vencer a la
muerte por lo tanto están ya
inevitablemente vencer a paramos a
ucraína
con russian negándose a aceptar una
tregua de pascua las celebraciones de
este año han sido moderadas y realizadas
con temor a bombardeos y fuego de
artillería en sabori allá en el este de
ucrania cerca de la línea del frente
los fieles llegaron para recibir sus
bendiciones de pascua y luego partieron
rápidamente
no entramos a la iglesia hicimos todo
rápido recibimos nuestras bendiciones
del párroco y ahora vamos camino a casa
en casa tendremos una reunión con
nuestra familia y se unieran nuestros
vecinos este año todo se hace muy rápido
en el capitolio los fieles también
dieron gracias al presidente y al
ejército a nuestra nación siempre ha
estado unida y hoy estamos demostrando
que es imposible asustarnos
todos los funcionarios ucranianos han
instado a la gente a no quedarse en los
servicios este año debido a la
preocupación de que las iglesias puedan
ser blanco de ataques con misiles
terminamos así esta emisión informativa
en france 24 pero que desde nuestra
pantalla y en france 24 punto com
[Música]